foreign
[Music]
briefing for Thursday September 22nd I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
last year China installed almost as many
robots in its factories as the rest of
the world combined according to new data
from the trade Group International
Federation of Robotics shipments of
industrial robots to China Rose 45 in
2021 from the year before these Factory
robots are programmable multi-purpose
devices that can automate the production
of electronics and cars and create metal
and plastic parts
so why is China Investing so heavily in
them right now and what does it mean for
the rest of the world
joining us to discuss that is our Asia
economics reporter Jason Douglas hi
Jason thanks for coming on the show hi
my pleasure so start with you know
what's the reason that China wants all
these new industrial robots
well there are a couple of short-term
factors and then there's a big long-term
one that's probably the best way to
think about it so the short term one is
there is something related to the
pandemic happening here which is that
particularly last year when we were all
sat at home ordering computer
peripherals and pelotons and all the
other stuff that we use to get this
through the work from home period demand
the Chinese factories just sort of shot
up and they had to meet this demand
somehow and so lots of them started
putting in robots the other advantage of
robots in the pandemic sense is they can
keep operating even whenever all the
workers are told to go home because of
covet zero but those kind of failing
comparisons the really big factor which
is a demographic one one which has
profound economic consequences for China
which is that its Workforce is shrinking
lots of countries workforces shrink it
as they get older but China it's
particularly Stark where are these
Robots coming from Japan mostly it's one
of the world's biggest manufacturer of
these industrial robots there are a
couple of very big companies that are
supplying Chinese factories Yaskawa is
one of them FANUC is another Kawasaki
also makes these industrial robots there
are a couple of European companies that
do it as well but having said that
China's getting better doing this
themselves so what we're seeing in the
data is the proportion of robots that
China is manufacturing and installing
domestically is increasing each year and
has been for the last few years and the
Chinese government has made a big push
into robotics how good are these robots
at manufacturing how easy is it for them
to replace these workers
I mean the robots China is putting in
are pretty well established kind of
industrial robots the kind of things
that we've probably heard and production
lines in the US and other parts of
Europe and Asia and the advanced world
for quite some time I mean they're these
big machines that can do things like
welding cutting heavy lifting then some
sort of very sort of precision type
operations these industrial robots that
China is buying so many of are really
multi-purpose programmable things so it
depends exactly what you want to use
them for but they can replace anywhere
from a couple of workers to maybe a
dozen or something I can give you an
example if you like so xcmg which is an
enormous Chinese state-owned
construction machinery company they I
think in their production line where
they were making loaders had managed to
replace sort of 10 workers with a single
robot that could do a particular job so
they are pretty sophisticated machines
that China is investing in for sure I
mean from a financial perspective I
would guess that these machines are very
expensive to buy how does that kind of
work out you know buying these big
machines versus hiring what used to be
at least cheap labor in China so what
you said is exactly right so labor used
to be very cheap in China and so if you
wanted to set up a factory you could
find thousands of workers and pay them
relatively little and there would always
be more people queuing at your door
looking for a job and prepared to work
for a low wage that Dynamic has
definitely changed in China as we
discussed earlier the workforce is
shrinking the number of people who want
to work in factories is is diminishing
and companies are finding it harder and
harder to find workers and they're
finding that they have to pay them a lot
more money to get them to come to work
at their factories and to stay there so
yes exactly a robot is a good investment
there's a big upfront cost but the
payback which will come over years and
so on is that you don't have these
ongoing labor costs to the same extent
that you would have done before I mean
one final thing we should say is the
workers that you do employ
will be better paid because they will
have to do more skilled tasks such as
fix the robot whenever it goes wrong or
work alongside the robot and all these
kind of things so it doesn't necessarily
mean that the big rise in unemployment
will inevitably follow from this at
least in China's case
so we know China's use of robots and
automation is growing what's the picture
like worldwide I mean how fast is
automation taking off globally
one of the reasons that China is moving
at such a pace to install these robots
is it's playing catch-up with other
advanced economies so in the US Japan
and places like South Korea and
Singapore which are big manufacturing
hubs uh the penetration of robots is
much greater than robot density which
simply measures how many robots there
are per 10 000 workers on a production
line is much much higher so China is
playing catch-up what we're seeing the
date is places like the US and South
Korea Japan are still installing robots
at a pretty rapid Pace there was a bit
of a blip during the pandemic for
reasons that are probably obvious not a
lot of investment was being made but
things are picking up again you see it
especially in particular sectors
Automotive is somewhere that's
installing a lot of robots things like
telecommunications new mobile phone
manufacturers they need increasing
Precision to do particular tasks
they're installing a lot of robots and
then places like Amazon right and
warehouses robotics is becoming
increasingly common and those kind of
operations as well I mean this is a
trend that we've been seeing talking
about for a number of years with China's
kind of speeding towards this oh what
does it mean for the global economy for
Global manufacturing is there anything
new that we should take away here
I think there are a couple of things one
is China is making increasingly
sophisticated products right so China
used to be thought of and still isn't to
a large extent the factory floor of the
world where anything cheap and cheerful
anything that needs to be made and huge
sort of numbers gets made
so what's happening is China is still
developing economically and it is
increasingly making more and more
complex products that is also one of the
drivers for this speed of Robotics
adoption
so China clearly wants to maintain its
dominance in manufacturing and this is
one of the ways it it believes that it
can do it so that's one consequence for
the global economy another one which is
slightly more speculative is what does
it mean for inflation over the kind of
long term we have a huge problem with
inflation at the minute one of the
reasons we didn't have an inflation
problem for the last 20 30 years is
because China plugged itself into the
global economy all its cheap labor and
cheap products help keep inflation dying
so if China automates rapidly I think
there's an interesting question around
will that help to keep cost on will that
help to keep Global inflationary
pressures more subdued again I think
that's an open question but I think
those are the two big ones so China's
staying on top in manufacturing and more
of an open question about inflation so I
guess we'll just have to keep watching
the automation trend for a number of
years to see how those two things play
out
all right that's our reporter Jason
Douglas thanks for joining us Jason my
pleasure thanks for having me
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]